Welcome to the debate today.
We're we're diving into what's
become, I think a really fraught
area in well, in modern American
discourse.
It's this deep semantic
confusion around the words
fascism and anti fascism.
I mean, these terms have,
they've shifted so much from
their historical origins that
people seem to be operating in
completely different
intellectual worlds now, and
it's causing real problems in
how we talk to each other
civically.
Absolutely.
It feels like two different
languages sometimes.
Exactly.
So the core question for us
today is this, when we talk
about fascism, should we really
keep it anchored to it's very
specific historical, political,
economic structure, you know,
Mussolini's corporatism?
Or is the way it's used much
more broadly now culturally as a
term opposing hierarchy,
tradition, global power
structures?
Is that usage actually more
useful for understanding
conflicts today?
A fundamental split.
Right.
And I'll be arguing that we
absolutely need to preserve that
precise corporatist definition.
I think intellectual clarity
frankly depends on it.
And I'm going to approach this,
well a bit differently.
While I get the appeal of
historical precision, it's
clean, it's academic, I want to
really explore the, let's call
it the utility of this newer,
much broader cultural
definition.
You know, whether it perfectly
matches the 1930s model or not.
This is how a huge number of
people actually understand and
frame their opposition to power
structures right now.
So we have to analyze how it
functions, not just judge its
historical accuracy.
OK, I see the setup, but let me
start by outlining why I think
that historical anchor is non
negotiable.
If we're aiming for political
clarity, the definition of
fascism isn't really optional.
When you go back and look at the
the foundational texts, the
history from the interwar
period, fascism really stood on
4 main pillars.
It was authoritarian, ultra
nationalist, militaristic.
And this is the crucial part,
corporatist corporatism, right?
This is the specific political
design that really separates
fascism from just any old
dictatorship or tyranny.
It's the idea of society as one
single body, a corpus where
private companies are
essentially forced to serve the
state's national agenda.
Yes, they kept their private
ownership on paper, but they
gave up their operational
independence to serve the
national machine.
And that mechanism, that's what
allowed Mussolini and others to
sell fascism as this unique
third way, You know, orderly,
efficient, better than messy
capitalism on one side and
revolutionary communism on the
other.
If you take corporatism out of
the definition, well then the
term just collapses into I don't
know what I maybe call bad
vibes, authoritarianism.
It becomes more of a moral
insult than a functional
political category that helps us
diagnose a specific structure.
Focusing only on Hitler's
horrific crimes, which of course
we must do morally, actually
misses the specific political
economic logic that made fascism
appealing to millions looking
for order and national renewal
back in the 20s and 30s.
That's a very strong case for
historical fidelity, and I
absolutely agree that
corporatism was the unique
engine, the defining feature of
that interwar fascism.
But the intellectual journey of
this term didn't stop there, did
it?
It evolved precisely because the
nature of structural
authoritarianism seemed to
change, or at least people's
understanding of it did.
You had thinkers later in the
20th century, people like
Umberto Eco, for instance, who
started talking about, ER,
fascism, these kind of eternal
structural tendencies towards
control, hierarchy, tradition,
worship that could pop up
without that specific 1930s
economic model of state
corporate fusion.
OK, so eco broadens it
culturally.
Exactly.
And the modern activist
definition has really latched on
to that kind of thinking.
It targets these very deep
seated cultural and societal
structures.
Things like patriarchy, borders,
flags, traditionalism, even
concepts like whiteness.
This shift, I argue, isn't
random.
It reflects a real sense of
urgency in society to challenge
forms of power that aren't just
about state control of industry,
but about cultural enforcement,
social norms.
And for many younger activists
today, this viewpoint is
definitely shaped by a global
perspective, often drawing
interestingly from a kind of
Maoist anti colonial struggle
lineage.
So in that world view, the
primary fascist force isn't some
rising state mirroring
Mussolini, it's the existing
global hegemon which is often
seen as America and the
structural inequalities that
system upholds and exports.
From that perspective, the
narrow corporatist definition
just doesn't feel adequate to
describe the source of the
oppression they see and feel
today.
I understand the lineage you're
tracing, but here's where I push
back.
I'm just not convinced that
treating diagnostic recision for
erceived utility is a good long
term strategy.
It feels like too stee a price
to pay.
Intellectually we have to be
able to alley what I'd call the
cororationism test.
When we look at olitical
movements or actors today, we
need to ask, are they actually
advocating for that merger of
private corporate power with
national state goals?
Is capital being forced to serve
the state's agenda?
The test.
Yeah, the test, because if we
ignore that core political
economic structure, how can we
possibly analyze threats
accurately?
Corporatism is what explains why
major industrialists, you know,
Krupp in Germany, Fiat in Italy,
why they went along with it,
they kept their company names,
their factories, but the
strategic reigns were handed
over to the regime all in the
name of national greatness,
order, efficiency.
Without that strict category of
corporatism, any strong form of
nationalism, any push for
cultural unity, any critique of
globalism risks being mislabeled
as fascism.
And that I think, makes us
blind.
It blinds us to the actual
mechanics of genuine state level
authoritarianism when it does
arise because we've sort of
we've worn out the word on
cultural disagreements.
OK, while I see the the neatness
and the historical sharpness of
the corporatism test, the
argument from the modern
perspective is precisely that
the target has shifted.
The main focus isn't the state
merging with industry anymore,
it's the cultural and social
forces that people see as
propping up existing power
structures.
But is that fascism?
Well, that's the core of the
debate, isn't it?
The activists would argue that
the real systemic threat now is
embedded in what the source
material calls the normie
continuum, right?
This whole framework of
traditional normative Western
life, pride and one's nation,
traditional family models,
Christianity, heteronormativity,
and so on.
For them, these cultural pillars
aren't neutral.
They are inherently
hierarchical.
They're exclusionary, and
therefore they are functionally
fascist because they enforce
what's seen as an oppressive
social order.
So the definition hasn't just
gotten wider, it's actually
shifted its focus from analyzing
a specific political system to
analyzing what they see as a
pervasive cultural system of
control.
And this semantic shift, they
believe, is necessary work.
It allows them to challenge the
very foundations of social
consensus, which they see as
essential to dismantling
structural inequality.
And that shift, that exact shift
you're describing, is what leads
directly to this non
reconcilable divide over anti
fascism that's tearing fault
lines through the country.
The two working definitions of
anti fascism today are almost
entirely disconnected from each
other.
Completely different worlds.
Yes, for for a huge number of
Americans the normies to use
that term again.
Anti fascism is basically
synonymous with America itself.
Their historical framework is
you know, the GI is landing on
D-Day, it's the US Constitution,
it's the nation that literally
fought and died in World War 2
to defeat historical fascism.
So for them, patriotism is the
ultimate anti fascism.
Waving the flag isn't
problematic, it's an act of
honouring that legacy, defending
democracy.
I absolutely agree the fracture
is profound, but for this
younger activist group their
understanding of anti fascism
often has frankly less to do
with honoring World War 2
veterans and much more
connection to global anti
colonial movements and as I
mentioned, even a kind of Maoist
cultural revolution lineage.
Their struggle isn't primarily
defined against Hitler or
Mussolini historically, but as
resistance against the current
global power structure, against
the dominant cultural and
economic system that America is
seeing to represent.
Can you elaborate on that Maoist
lineage connection?
Because that seems key.
Well, when we talk about that
lineage, we're referring to an
ideological framework that tends
to view the entire Western
establishment, and that includes
its liberal democracy, its
capitalism, its cultural norms
as inherently imperialistic and
structurally oppressive on a
global scale.
O Within that framework, being
antifascist means rejecting the
fundamental political and
cultural assumptions of the West
because those are seeing as the
very things perpetuating global
inequality and hierarchy.
It's a really fundamental
disagreement about who the
actual enemy is.
Is it the historical Axis powers
defeated in 1945?
Or is it the present day
configuration of global power
often symbolized by the US?
And the consequence of
stretching the term that far is
this profound disconnect, this
mutual incomprehension that
frankly risks breaking down
democratic communication
entirely.
You have older generations whose
parents might have literally
fought fascists in Europe or the
Pacific, feeling like their
basic patriotism, their
traditional values, are suddenly
being framed as somehow
fascistic.
The gas lighting effect.
Exactly.
When the word fascist gets
stretched so thin that it
includes someone flying a
national flag or holding
traditional views on family, the
level of anger, the alienation,
it just skyrockets.
It makes any kind of civic
consensus almost impossible
because the two sides can't even
agree on the meaning of the
words they're using, let alone
the moral framework behind them.
You know the person hanging in
American flag thinks they're
honoring their grandfather, the
anti fascist war hero.
The activist looks at that same
flag and sees the symbol of
global hegemony and structural
oppression, making the flag
waver, in their view,
functionally supportive of a
fascist system.
That gap, it's dangerous.
It feels almost impossible to
bridge in political dialogue.
I understand the concern about
communication breakdown, but I'd
argue the democratic risk isn't
just about semantics.
It's also arguably rooted in the
very real structural issues like
persistent economic and racial
inequalities that maybe pushed
this definitional shift in the
1st place precisely because the
old terms felt inadequate to
address them.
However, let me pivot slightly
and offer a structural critique
that kind of stands apart from
the strict corporatist
definition debate.
It's something I think you might
find interesting because it
touches on the mechanics of
power within movements
themselves, specifically the
structure of the modern activist
movement, particularly it's
vanguard element.
OK, I'm listening.
Tell me more about this modern
vanguard.
Well, if you look back at the
history of certain authoritarian
movements, particularly
classical communism, there was
this concept of the vanguard,
right?
A small, ideologically committed
elite group.
And often this vanguard ended up
exploiting the very group it
claimed to represent.
You know, Lenin needed a
vanguard that arguably exploited
the proletariat.
The workers became fuel for the
revolution, not necessarily
partners in power.
And we can perhaps see a
structural echo of that dynamic
today.
Some critiques suggest that the
modern activist vanguard can
sometimes exploit vulnerable
groups, say racial minorities,
trans individuals, other
marginalized people, using them
as sort of moral props in their
campaigns.
Moral props like human Shields,
almost.
In a sense, deploying their
identities and suffering as
symbols to justify radical
demands, sometimes treating the
individuals themselves, to
borrow that phrase from the
source material like useful
Kleenex, discardable once their
symbolic value is used up.
That is, yes, that's a very
compelling structural parallel,
and it points to, I think, a
deep ethical and maybe
operational flaw within parts of
the modern movement.
When you see that kind of
dynamic of vanguard using, let's
say, radical chic or weaponized
identity politics, it does feel
like a cynical form of
exploitation that echoes some
historical authoritarian
tactics.
It suggests a pursuit of power
that feels profoundly
undemocratic, actually
exploiting the marginalized to
legitimize the vanguard's own
agenda.
That seems like a structural
problem, regardless of whether
they label themselves anti
fascist or anti hegemon or
something else entirely.
Exactly my point.
But here's the crucial turn, at
least for this side of the
argument.
Doesn't this structural
observation, this exploitation
by a self appointed elite,
actually reinforce the idea that
the real targets of opposition
today should be broader than
just the 1930s economic model?
This very behavior suggests that
the core issues are about
structural power dynamics, about
the mechanics of hierarchy and
domination themselves.
It implies we need to critique
the focuses on systemic
oppression that goes beyond just
state corporate mergers and
includes these cultural, racial
and social forms of
exploitation.
So the Vanguard's bad behavior
proves the need for the broader
critique.
In a way, yes, if the ultimate
aim is genuinely anti
authoritarianism.
If it's about challenging
oppressive hierarchies wherever
they exist, then focusing only
on the specific economic
structure of interwar fascism
might seem well insufficient to
really analyze the complex,
often culturally enforced power
dynamics we face in the 21st
century.
The cultural critique, however
messy or prone to misuse it
might be, becomes functional
precisely because it attempts to
identify and target those
pervasive forms of exploitation
and hierarchy.
I do understand the desire for a
framework that addresses
contemporary power dynamics, and
that structural critique of the
vanguard is is quite powerful,
but I have to come back in
conclusion to stressing the
absolute need for intellectual
precision.
The word fascism carries immense
historical and moral weight.
If we let it dissolve into just
a general purpose term for any
hierarchy we dislike or any
tradition we find objectionable,
we essentially destroy its
meaning.
It just becomes a potent but
ultimately empty moral insult.
To keep our ability to diagnose
specific political threats, I
maintain that fascism must
remain defined by its core
political economic structure,
corporatism.
That gives us a clear, sharp,
admittedly narrow, but effective
tool to identify genuinely
analogous authoritarian
political machines if and when
they reemerge.
We simply can't afford to
sacrifice that diagnostic
capability for the sake of a
broader cultural critique, no
matter how necessary that
critique might be in its own
right, perhaps under a different
name.
And I suppose I'll conclude by
acknowledging that yes,
definitions matter deeply, and
this semantic drift, as we've
called it, has undeniably
created a state of profound
confusion and division.
But the reality we face is that
these newer, broader definitions
of fascism and anti fascism are
already active, functioning
forces shaping our political
landscape.
We're not just split by policy
anymore, we're split by the very
definitions of what we're
fighting against and fighting
for.
We can't simply wish away this
new usage or demand that half
the country suddenly reverts to
a 1988 textbook definition when
there lived social and political
reality has already generated a
working, if perhaps historically
imprecise alternative.
They find meaningful.
Well, I think we've certainly
laid bare the core of the
conflict here.
It's this tension between
prioritizing clarity and
historical accuracy to diagnose
the mechanisms of state power
versus prioritizing scope and
perceived utility to critique
existing cultural and structural
hierarchies.
And perhaps the most crucial
take away is that both sides,
operating within their own
definitional frameworks,
genuinely believe they are the
ones fighting for democracy and
against tyranny.
The tragedy is that neither side
fully grasps or perhaps accepts
the fundamental premises and
definitions of the other.
And that Divergent, makes
building any kind of shared
civic language incredibly
difficult right now.
So the listener is left, as
always, to weigh these
perspectives.
Is clarity, anchored in the
historical precision of
corporatism the better lens?
Or does the scope offered by the
contemporary cultural critique,
despite its ambiguities, provide
a more useful tool for
understanding the conflicts
shaping our present and future?
Welcome to the Deep.
Thank you for joining.
Us today we're tackling
something a bit different.
Not a policy and not a specific
event, but just one word.
Just one word, yeah, but maybe
the most loaded word in American
politics right now.
Fascism.
It feels like it's everywhere
and it's tearing things apart.
But the sources we've looked at,
they suggest something
interesting.
The problem isn't necessarily
fascism itself, but that nobody
agrees on what the word even
means.
Exactly.
It's like everyone's shouting
fire but pointing at completely
different things.
Yeah, we've got, based on the
academic and cultural analysis
we reviewed, essentially 3
different definitions floating
around 3 irreconcilable
definitions.
And that's what we're going to
try and unpack today.
That's the mission for this deep
dive.
We want to look at these three
faces, the original historical
meaning, what you might call the
normie or traditional American
view, and then this newer
cultural or activist definition.
Right.
And look, this isn't about
picking sides.
It's about understanding the
political science, the history,
how this term evolved
culturally, how it got
stretched, you know, into
basically a catch all insult.
Yeah, it's lost its precision.
Completely and the sources are
really clear.
To get any clarity back, we have
to go back to the start, back to
the definition that used to be
standard.
And Palacio, I say back in the
late 80s, early 90s, OK.
And that definition, the one we
seem to have forgotten, it's
centered on a specific concept,
corporatism.
Corporatism, that's the key we
need to recover.
It's absolutely critical.
Without it, the the word just
becomes, well, like you said, an
insult, a moral judgement, not a
political analysis.
OK, so let's go back to that
political science one O 1 class
from say 1988, like our sources
mentioned.
Yeah.
What was that clean definition
they were teaching them?
Well, the template was really
Mussolini's Italy.
An academic saw it fitting into
a specific historical box with a
four key elements. 4 elements
OK.
One, it was interwar, tied
specifically to that period
between World War One and World
War 2.
Got it.
Historical Context.
Two authoritarian meaning, you
know, total state control over
politics.
No real opposition allowed.
Standard dictatorship stuff 3.
Ultra nationalist obsessed with
the nation, National glory
expansion often based on some
kind of mythic past, and four,
the crucial 1.
Corporatist.
Right, corporatist.
And this is where it gets
tricky, isn't it?
Because today when people hear
corporatism, they immediately
think of like Amazon or Google
influencing the government, big
companies.
Exactly.
That's the modern common usage,
but the historical political
science term totally different.
It comes from the Latin corpus.
Corpus meaning.
Body.
Precisely.
The idea was to reorganize
society itself to function like
one giant single body, the
nation.
OK, so like an Organism?
Yeah, the state, led by the
dictator, acts as the brain.
And then every group of society,
labor unions, businesses,
farmers, churches, professional
groups, they're all seen as
essential organs.
Organs within the body.
Right.
And these organs aren't supposed
to compete or pursue their own
interests.
They're forced into these state
controlled structures, these
corporations in the corpus
sense, and they function under
total state discipline, all for
the supposed health and strength
of the national body.
So it's about enforced unity,
total social discipline through
organization.
Why was that specific model so
appealing back in the 1920s and
30s?
Well, you have to remember the
context. after World War One,
liberal democracy looked kind of
shaky, didn't it?
Lots of economic chaos, strikes,
political infighting.
It seemed weak, inefficient.
And the alternative was
communism, which scared a lot of
people.
Exactly.
Communism, with its calls to
abolish private property and its
violent revolution, seemed
destructive.
So fascism presented itself as
this dynamic third way.
A third way between weak
democracy and destructive
communism.
Right.
It promised the order and unity
of communism, but without, you
know, getting rid of private
property entirely.
And it promised the dynamism of
capitalism, but without the
messy competition and class
struggle.
It looked modern, efficient,
decisive.
And it tapped into that ultra
nationalism, the promise of
national rebirth, what the
source is called Palin Genesis.
That was huge, this idea of
returning to a glorious mythical
past through radical unified
action.
Now corporatism was the
mechanism to achieve that total
unity needed for rebirth.
OK, so understanding what it is
also means understanding what it
isn't.
The sources really emphasize
comparing it to the
alternatives.
Let's start with communism.
Because people mix those up
constantly.
Where's the bright line
according to this original
definition?
The bright line is really about
private property and how the
economy is controlled.
Classical Marxism, you know,
aims to abolish private property
completely.
The state takes over everything.
Factories, farms, the works.
Right.
The state literally owns the
means of production on behalf of
the proletariat.
It's total nationalization.
OK, so how did fascism handle
property differently?
It seems sneakier maybe?
You could say that, or maybe
more cynical.
As one source put it, fascism
let's private individuals keep
the title deeds.
You still own your factory.
Say your Fiat in Italy or Krupp
in Germany.
So you keep your wealth, your
status.
On the surface yes, but it's
ownership in name only.
The sources call it neutered
capitalism.
You're not deciding what to
produce based on the market or
profit anymore.
The state tells you what to
make.
Exactly.
You produce what the state
orders for the National Plan,
which usually meant weapons,
gear for the military, stuff for
the war machine.
So the shell of capitalism is
there, but the state is running
the show from behind the scenes
dictating output.
Pretty much.
You become essentially a highly
managed government contractor.
You've lost your economic
autonomy.
Even if you keep the factory
sign, it keeps the structure but
empties it of independent
function.
That's a really important
distinction.
Control without direct
ownership.
Yeah, what about the contrast
with liberal democracy?
That was a system fascism was
directly attacking, wasn't.
It absolutely.
Liberal democracy, in theory at
least, sees the government more
like a referee.
Setting the rules of the game,
enforcing contracts, protecting
rights.
Right.
But largely letting individuals,
businesses, different social
classes compete within those
rules.
Disagreement, political parties,
labor unions, fighting for
wages.
That's all as normal, even
healthy, in a free society.
And fascism saw all that as
weakness, chaos worse than
weakness.
It saw it as poison, corrosive
to the national body.
All that competition, all those
individual rights asserted
against the state, all that
class struggle and divide of the
nation made it weak.
So fascism demanded the
opposite.
Total unity, total discipline.
The individual doesn't matter.
Only the nation matters.
Individual rights are
suppressed.
Class conflict is crushed.
Political opposition is
eliminated.
Everything has to be
subordinated to this goal of
national rebirth and power.
It's that fusion, then the
authoritarian leader, the ultra
nationalist ideology, and this
specific corporatist economic
structure forcing everyone into
line.
That was fascism, historically
speaking.
That was the specific political
category, yes, interwar,
European, defined by those
elements.
OK, so here's a question that
pushes back a bit.
Based on that definition, if
fascism involves this massive
fusion of state and key
industries, with the government
directing production, why don't
these sources then label things
we see today, like, say, the
2008 bank bailouts, or the huge
military industrial complex, or
even the close ties between
government and big tech?
Now, why isn't that called
fascism under this definition?
It sounds kind of similar.
That's a really sharp question,
and it highlights why that
original definition was so
precise, the sources
acknowledge.
Yes, there's definitely a lot of
collaboration, sometimes
worrying collaboration, between
government and big corporations
in modern economies.
You could call it crony
capitalism, maybe regulatory
capture, maybe even oligarchy.
But not fascism.
Not in that original, specific
sense, because classical
corporatism required more than
just collaboration or bailouts.
It required that total
organizational discipline across
all sectors, enforced by a
single party.
Authoritarian state explicitly
suppressing individual profit
motives for a Grand National
plan, usually war focused.
So the political structure is
key, the authoritarian single
party rule, the ultra
nationalism.
Exactly.
Modern state capitalism, even
when it looks really cozy
between government and business,
still mostly operates within a
framework where companies are
competing for favors or
contracts within a system that
still allows for political
opposition, Free Press, some
level of market dynamics,
however distorted.
Take away the specific
authoritarian political shell
and the ultra nationalist
ideology and you don't have
fascism anymore.
You might have something else
bad like oligarchy, but it's a
different category.
So stripping out corporatism is
what broke the definition
without that specific economic
and political structure.
It just becomes a generic term
for any authoritarian regime you
don't like or worse as the
sources say, just bad vibes.
Authoritarianism, a moral
insult, not a tool for analysis.
And that's the shift that set
the stage for the confusion we
have now.
Precisely that loss of
analytical precision is Ground
Zero for the semantic war we're
living through.
OK, that historical baseline is
super helpful.
Now let's pivot to how the word
fractured in popular culture.
The sources talk about this
normie definition that emerged
after World War 2, the kind of
broad, mainstream American
understanding.
Right.
This is the definition that you
know generations of Americans
grew up with, especially shaped
by the Cold War experience.
For them, fascism wasn't really
an abstract political theory.
It was Hitler.
It was Hitler, Mussolini, Tojo,
the Nazis, the Holocaust, World
War Two.
It was a specific, concrete
historical evil that America
fought and defeated.
I closed chapter, died in 1945
in a bunker in Berlin.
Pretty much it was this clear
enemy vanquished by American
GI's and that led directly to
the Corollary.
That America is anti fascist.
Inherently so.
Anti fascism wasn't some radical
ideology, it was American
patriotism.
It was the flag, the
constitution, Uncle Sam, the
greatest generation narrative
defending freedom was anti
fascism.
So if you were a patriotic
American, you were
definitionally an anti fascist.
There was no tension there.
Not at all.
And this got hardwired during
the Cold War, right?
Because with fascism defeated,
the new global enemy became
communism.
Another totalitarian ideology
that America opposed.
Exactly.
An ideology that explicitly
rejected democracy and
individual liberty.
So America's whole identity,
it's sort of civic firmware got
updated.
America was the leader of the
free world standing against
communism, and since communism
was bad and fascism was bad, and
America opposed communism.
America was fundamentally the
good guy.
The anti fascist nation.
Calling America itself fascist
would have sounded completely
nonsensical, like a
contradiction in terms.
It's violated the core national
self-image.
It was unthinkable for decades.
OK so that's one deeply
ingrained understanding the
normie view.
Fascism WWII bad guys anti
fascism America.
Now let's look at the other side
of this golf the activist
definition.
The sources trace this one back,
interestingly, to an essay by
Umberto Eco.
Yeah, Eco's 1995 essay or
Fascism, which is a brilliant
piece by the way.
Eco lived through Italian
fascism, and he was trying to
identify sort of recurring
cultural tendencies or warning
signs that might signal a return
of something like fascism.
He had that list of 14
characteristics right.
Things like rejection of
modernism, fear of difference,
obsession with plots.
Exactly.
Cult of tradition,
Irrationalism.
Disagreement is treason.
Contempt for the weak.
It was meant as a kind of
flexible checklist of cultural
symptoms, not as a rigid
definition of a state structure
like the old corporatist model.
But the sources argue that essay
maybe unintentionally opened a
door.
What was meant as warning signs
started getting used as the
definition itself.
That seems to be the argument.
It sort of slipped its
historical moorings once.
You didn't need corporatism or a
specific interwar context
anymore.
Fascism can become, well, almost
anything culturally conservative
or traditionalist that activists
opposed.
So the definition shifted from a
political economic system to a
set of cultural traits.
Right.
The new fascism wasn't
necessarily about state control
of industry.
It became about hierarchy,
tradition, patriarchy, strong
borders, national flags,
traditional religious
institutions, even concepts like
whiteness or Christian identity.
The target changed
fundamentally.
Completely, the focus moved from
the structure of government to
the enforcement of cultural
norms deemed oppressive.
And this leads to a really
crucial point the sources make
about the lineage of this newer
anti fascism.
They argue it often owes less to
fighting Mussolini and more to
Maoism.
That seems like a leap.
It sounds jarring at first, but
the argument centers on the
goals and methods.
Maoism, particularly in its anti
colonial phase, wasn't just
about economics, it was about a
cultural revolution.
Destroying the old ways, the old
hierarchies.
Exactly.
Erasing traditional culture,
challenging patriarchy,
attacking religion, seeing all
existing structures as
inherently oppressive and
needing to be overthrown through
constant struggle, A kind of
permanent revolution.
The focus was on dismantling the
cultural superstructure of
power.
So the idea is that some modern
activist anti fascism adopts
that cultural revolutionary
framework, seeing traditional
American culture or Western
culture as the oppressive
structure that needs
dismantling.
That's the connection the
sources draw.
This strand of anti fascism sees
America not as the defeater of
fascism, but as the source of
global oppression, the hegemon,
the colonizer, the enforcer of
hierarchy through its culture,
its borders, its traditions.
So fascism becomes a label for
that system of perceived
oppression.
Right.
It's not about Iladus anymore.
It's about challenging whiteness
or patriarchy or capitalism or
borders, things seen as pillars
of an oppressive system.
And modern antifa movements,
while having roots in 1930s anti
Nazi street fights, often seem
more aligned with that broader
anti capitalist, anti colonial
cultural struggle.
The enemy is the systemic
identity itself.
Wow.
OK, now the semantic gulf
becomes crystal clear.
It's enormous.
It's huge.
You have the normie thinking I'm
anti fascist.
My grandpa stormed the beaches
of Normandy under that flag to
fight Nazis.
And the activists thinking
you're a fascist because you
wave that flag and uphold the
system my grandpa fought
against.
Or maybe the system that
exploited people globally?
The exact same symbols, the same
words mean opposite things.
The language has been totally
inverted.
And this applies to democracy
too, doesn't it?
Absolutely.
For the normie, democracy is
about the process.
One person, one vote, free
speech, rule of law, majority
rule with minority rights, the
liberal ideal.
Basically how we make decisions.
OK.
And for the activists?
It's often about the outcome.
Does the result produce equity?
Does it protect the most
vulnerable groups?
Does it dismantle oppressive
structures?
If an election or a court ruling
doesn't achieve those outcomes,
then the process itself might be
labeled undemocratic or fascist,
regardless of whether the rules
were followed.
So 1 focuses on procedure, the
other on results defined by
social justice schools.
Pretty much.
And when those two definitions
collide, well, you see the
arguments we have today.
People are using the same words,
Fascism, anti fascism,
democracy, but they're operating
in completely different
conceptual universes.
They're not even having the same
conversation.
Not even close.
It's like trying to play chess
when one person thinks the
pieces move normally and the
other thinks the bishops are
actually spaceships.
It just collapses into
incoherence and anger.
That gap is already massive, but
the sources point out another
layer, something that adds like
cognitive dissonance, especially
for the normie side.
And that's the memory hole
around the Global War on Terror.
Yeah, the 20 year firmware
update that got well wiped
almost overnight.
Right from roughly 2001 until
maybe 20/15/2016, the entire
national focus, the definition
of US versus them, was about
fighting Islamic extremism.
For two decades, national unity,
patriotism, defending freedom,
it was all framed around
fighting Al Qaeda, the Taliban,
later ISIS.
The enemy was explicitly non
western, anti democratic,
religiously motivated.
That was the threat.
Standing against that was being
a good American and anti fascist
in the sense of defending
western democracy.
Heroes were soldiers fighting
overseas.
Patriotism meant supporting the
troops flying the flag.
And then, almost whiplash fast.
Particularly after 2015 or so,
that entire framework seems to
get buried.
Suddenly, the discourse shifts
dramatically.
The main threat isn't external
anymore, It's internal.
It's systemic Racism,
patriarchy, white supremacy, the
very structures and symbols that
were central to the GWOT
identity.
So the people who lived through
that maybe served in the
military or just absorbed that
culture, they experience a kind
of sudden reversal.
A.
Huge reversal.
The language changed completely.
The things that defined you as a
patriot during the GWOT may be
flag waving, nationalism,
Suspicion of certain foreign
ideologies are now potentially
defined as the problem as
fascist tendencies, often by a
younger generation of activists
who came up of age after the
peak of the GWOT and mainly know
the newer cultural critique.
That must create incredible
confusion and resentment.
Absolutely.
It feels like a betrayal, like
the rules change without
explanation.
It makes it very hard for that
normie population to take the
new critique seriously because
it seems to come out of nowhere
and invalidates their own lived
experience and sacrifices.
And that feeds into another
point.
The sources raise the cynicism
generated when these critiques
seem disconnected from reality
on the ground.
They use the term NMB paradox.
Not in my backyard.
Yeah, this gets at the perceived
hypocrisy.
The argument is that often the
loudest voices condemning
systemic fascism or demanding
diversity and inclusion are
coming from places or
demographics that are actually
quite insulated and homogeneous.
Places that talk the talk but
don't walk the walk.
That's the perception.
The sources point to examples
like, say, very liberal states
or cities where the population
outside of maybe a few core
urban areas is overwhelmingly
white or affluent.
Think about Oregon's history,
founded with racial exclusion
clauses, or parts of New England
or the Pacific Northwest.
So the critique comes from
people who don't live with the
complexities of diversity
day-to-day.
That's the charge.
Meanwhile, you might have, say,
a working class person in a
truly diverse area, maybe a
place like Northern Virginia or
parts of Texas or California,
living next door to immigrants
from all over the world, dealing
with the real, sometimes messy
realities of multicultural life
every single day.
And that person gets called a
fascist by someone living in a
much less diverse, maybe more
privileged environment.
Exactly, and that feels deeply
unfair and hypocritical to them.
They see people preaching
diversity from afar while
they're the ones actually
navigating it.
It makes it easy to dismiss the
entire critique as just elite
posturing, not a genuine
concern.
The do as I say, not as I do
problem.
Right, the NMBY phenomenon.
Supporting affordable housing or
diverse schools in theory, but
resisting them when they're
proposed for your neighborhood
fuels that cynicism.
It allows the normie to say,
see, they don't really believe
it themselves.
It's just a way to signal virtue
or gain power.
Which brings us to maybe the
most challenging concept from
the sources, this idea of the
vanguard and political
exploitation drawing on Marxist
theory.
If the critique seems
hypocritical, where does its
moral force come from?
This is a complex argument.
It starts with the idea that
most revolutionary movements
historically needed a vanguard,
a core group of dedicated,
ideologically committed
activists to lead the charge.
The revolutionaries who know the
way forward, right?
But the vanguard is usually
small.
To gain power, they need to
mobilize or claim to represent a
larger group.
They need to exploit the
grievances or identity of a
segment of the population to
fuel the revolution.
OK, so who did classical
movements exploit?
Classical communism claimed to
represent and mobilize the
industrial working class, the
proletariat.
Maoism focused on the peasants
and later the youth during the
Cultural Revolution.
And in the context of modern
American activism, according to
these sources, who is the
exploited group?
The argument is that the
vanguard, today often seen as
educated, relatively privileged
activists, derives its moral
authority and political leverage
by claiming to speak for the
most vulnerable and marginalized
groups, racial minorities, LGBTQ
plus individuals, immigrants,
the disabled.
So these groups become moral
props?
That sounds harsh.
It is harsh, but that's the
critique presented.
The idea is that the Vanguard
uses the suffering and identity
of these groups as a shield and
a weapon.
We speak for the oppressed,
therefore our cause is righteous
and you must yield to us.
It's described as moving beyond
radical chic into something more
instrumental.
The focus isn't necessarily
empowering those groups
directly, but using their
symbolic weight to advance the
Vanguard's own political goals.
That's the cynical
interpretation offered by the
sources.
Yes, the vanguard positions
itself as the indispensable
protector and interpreter of the
vulnerable, gaining status and
power through that role.
And this ties into a historical
pattern of disposability.
Sadly, yes.
History is littered with
examples of groups who are
championed during a revolution
only to be discarded or even
purged once the vanguard
achieved power and didn't need
them anymore.
The sources mentioned Lenin's
useful idiots.
Right.
People who genuinely believed in
the cause and helped the
revolution, but were naive about
the leadership's ultimate
intentions and were often
sidelined or eliminated later.
Think about the intellectuals
who supported Stalin or.
The Afghan translators who
worked with the USA.
Brutal contemporary example
risked everything based on
promises, believed they were
part of the project, and then
found themselves abandoned when
political calculations changed,
their usefulness expired.
Or the Red Guards in China you
mentioned earlier.
A.
Classic case.
Young, fervent, empowered by Mao
to tear down the old order
during the Cultural Revolution.
They were the engine of change.
But once Mao consolidated
control and needed stability,
not chaos, millions of those
same Red Guards were exiled to
the countryside, imprisoned or
killed.
They had served their
destructive purpose and became
inconvenient.
So the underlying fear or the
critique is that the modern
vanguard, while genuinely
believing they're fighting for
justice.
Might be setting up the very
groups they claim to protect for
a similar betrayal down the
line.
That's the chilling implication.
The vanguard sees itself as the
permanent benevolent guardian.
But the normie often
instinctively distrust this
dynamic, sensing the potential
for exploitation and the
instability of a moral authority
built on symbolism rather than,
say, shared experience or
genuine representation.
And the historical irony is that
the revolutionaries themselves
are often consumed by the
revolutions they start.
Absolutely.
Once the old order smashed, the
new order needs administrators,
not agitators.
The skills required are
different.
The radical energy that was
useful for tearing down becomes
a threat to the new stability.
So the vanguard often finds
itself purged by the very power
structure it helped create.
It's a recurring tragedy.
OK, let's try to pull these
threads together.
We've mapped out this huge
semantic divide.
On one side you have the normie
definition.
Rooted in World War Two in the
Cold War.
For them fascism is basically
Hitler and the Axis powers
defeated in 45 life.
Anti fascism is fundamentally
American patriotism.
The flag, the Constitution and
democracy means the process.
One person, one vote.
Free and fair elections.
And on the other side, the
activists definition.
Rooted more in cultural
critique, maybe drawing
unconsciously or consciously on
anti colonial or Maoist ideas.
For them, fascism isn't just a
historical regime, it's embedded
in current structures, borders,
traditions, hierarchies, maybe
whiteness or patriarchy.
Anti fascism is the ongoing
struggle against those
structures and democracy means
the outcome.
Equity, justice, protection for
the marginalized. 2 completely
different operating systems
trying to run on the same
national hardware.
Yeah, and causing system crashes
all over the place.
And the sources suggest this
isn't just an internal American
problem.
It has global ripple effects,
right, in terms of alliances and
how people see the world.
It really does.
The argument is that this deep
confusion, this feeling among
normies that their own country's
cultural elites now label their
basic values fascist, pushes
them away from traditional
allies.
Away from like Western Europe,
NATO, the EU.
Yeah, those places often seem
aligned with the activist
cultural critique, sometimes
looking down condescendingly on
American populism or
traditionalism.
So instead you see a growing
affinity, maybe not for the
regimes themselves, but for the
values projected by certain
populous nations.
Like where?
Places like Russia, Hungary,
maybe Brazil under Bolsonaro,
India under Modi, the BRICS
nations in some ways.
Why are the connection there?
Because those nations, or at
least their leaders, often
publicly champion the very
things being labeled fascist by
activists in the West.
Strong national identity,
traditional family values,
religious observance, secure
borders, Things that resonate
with the normie definition of,
well, just normal life.
So when your own side calls your
values fascist, you look for
someone, anyone, who validates
them.
It creates strange bedfellows,
doesn't it?
America is, at its core, a very
populous country.
When its own elites seem hostile
to that populism, people look
elsewhere for affirmation.
It really highlights the danger
of the language breaking down.
When words lose their shared
meaning, they stop being tools
for understanding and just
become clubs to beat each other
with.
Exactly.
And the source material had that
striking metaphor, didn't it?
Words like skateboards.
Skateboards.
Explain that the idea was
skateboards were once just
simple tools for transportation
or maybe a subcultures
recreation.
But now imagine someone taking
that skateboard, not riding it,
but just swinging it like a
weapon, hitting people over the
head with it.
So the word fascism started as a
specific tool for political
analysis.
And now it's been repurposed,
stripped of its original
function and just wielded as a
blunt instrument off against the
very people, the normies, who
thought they were the original
anti fascists.
And the ultimate casualty is
clarity.
If everyone you disagree with is
a fascist, then the word means
nothing.
We lose the ability to identify
the actual specific threat of
that historical corporatist,
ultra nationalist
authoritarianism if it ever
truly reemerged.
We lose the vocabulary to even
recognize it.
And likewise, if democracy only
means getting the outcomes I
want, then it's not democracy
anymore either.
It's just raw power politics
cloaked in democratic language.
It feels like we're trapped in
an echo chamber where both sides
think they're the resistance.
Yeah, one side fighting fascism,
the other fighting what they
perceive as communism or
cultural Marxism, both convinced
they're saving the country from
the other.
Which leaves us with a pretty
sobering final thought for our
listeners to chew on when the
basic words we use to describe
our political life, fascism,
anti fascism, democracy becomes
so contested, so broken that
they mean opposite things to
different groups.
How can a country even function?
How do you find common ground or
even have a coherent debate?
Can you rebuild a shared
vocabulary once it's fractured
this badly?
Or are we just talking past each
other into oblivion?
It makes you wonder if the
semantic split isn't just a
symptom, but maybe the cause of
feeling like we're living in two
fundamentally different
countries occupying the same
map.
That's the uncomfortable
question, isn't it?
Something to think about.
Thank you for joining us for
this deep dive.
Is looking at an essay arguing
that fascism as a term has
fractured right into these
incompatible historical, normie
and activist meanings, leading
to this national paralysis.
And what jumps out immediately
is how clearly you identify that
semantic gulf using your own
story.
GW Tuberlin referencing ECO.
It's a really powerful way into
a very thorny subject.
Yeah, that personal framing and
the depth are definitely the
essays foundation.
It's sharp, it's persuasive, and
it puts its finger on a a real
cultural fault line we need to
talk about.
So we're just going to focus on
maybe four key areas, not about
fundamental flaws, but more
about how to maximize the
impact, make it even more
rigorous, moving it from, say,
sharp commentary to really
definitive political science
analysis.
Right, let's dive in.
First up, maybe a structural
point, the idea of corporatism,
which you rightly identify as
the historical academic core of
the definition.
It's introduced early, but then
it feels a bit exiled to the
Postscript and glossary, and
that diminishes its power as the
central analytical tool running
through the main argument.
Yeah, I agree that structural
choice, it has real consequences
for how the argument lands.
Because the main comparison you
draw that deep dive into the
normie versus the activist view,
it ends up playing out mostly
along cultural lines, you know,
Nazis versus anti hierarchy.
And because corporatism, the
actual like political economic
engine of historical fascism,
isn't fully unpacked until
later, well, a reader could
potentially skim it and just see
another piece on cultural war
word games.
Instead of the powerful
reassertion of political science
rigor, it clearly aims to be OK.
I get that.
If the whole point is, the word
drifted away from its historical
anchor.
Exactly.
Then that anchor, the economic
reality needs to be constantly
present right there in the
middle, like a fixed point we
keep coming back to.
Precisely.
If we wait until the very end to
explain that core idea, state
control of private production,
which is the key difference from
communism, right, we've missed
the chance to ground the whole
thing in serious political
economy from the start.
It leaves the comparison between
the three faces feeling maybe a
bit too philosophical or
cultural, rather than deeply
rooted in political structure.
So the suggestion here is really
about integration.
We need to weave that definitive
corporatist criteria, what you
call the academic face, more
dynamically into the main
comparison in the middle.
Make it a constant benchmark,
not just a footnote or an
afterthought.
OK, so practically how would
that look?
Well, take the section where
you're describing the activist
definition.
You talk about how they see
fascism through this lens of
anti colonial struggle, anti
whiteness, that sort of thing.
Right there.
You could bring in corporatism
immediately for that sharp
contrast.
Maybe a sentence like.
While activists frame fascism
primarily as anti colonial
struggle, the rigorous
historical analysis anchors it
specifically to state control of
private production.
Corporatism and economic
arrangement almost entirely
absent from this modern
critique.
See.
It cuts right through.
Ah, OK, And then that crucial
stuff from the Postscript about
how fascism differs from
communism because private
ownership is neutered, not
eliminated.
That needs to be woven in much
earlier too.
Definitely pull that into the
main text, right where you first
introduced the three faces.
It immediately raises the stakes
for the historical definition,
gives it the weight it needs to
properly anchor the whole
comparison.
Got it.
That simple shift really
reframes the piece as a core
political analysis, not just a
commentary on semantics.
Exactly.
It ensures the rigor is front
and center.
OK, strong, start building on
that structural gravity.
The next point is about balance,
right?
To make sure the whole critique
feels logically robust, perhaps
strengthening the political
weight given to the normie
perspective and it's sort of
current geopolitical side.
Yes, I think that's key.
The essay does a fantastic job,
really sharp work dismantling
the contradictions in the
activist model.
You know, the Maoist threads,
the NIMBY paradox you point out,
the disposable vanguard.
That's all very effective.
But the normie perspective,
while you treat it with real
empathy, you know grandpa fought
the Nazis.
The commitment to tradition.
It feels largely defined by what
it reacts against.
The ghost of Hitler, fear of
communism, fear of radical
change.
It doesn't quite get the same
depth of analysis when it comes
to its own sort of positive
political program, what it's
for, not just what it's against.
And that's the risk, isn't it?
If we don't explore that
positive program, the essay
might feel slightly tilted, like
it's primarily critiquing the
activist view rather than
mapping 3 genuinely distinct and
potent worldviews.
Because the normie view isn't
just nostalgia, it's an active
global political stance right
now.
Right.
So the recommendation is to
flush that out more, develop the
analysis of that bricks populism
alignment you mentioned, explore
it as a real positive political
project.
Yeah, exactly.
Thinking about sovereignty,
national pride, tradition,
cultural borders, what actually
defines the normies contemporary
view of anti fascism or
democracy in a positive sense?
OK, so maybe expand that
paragraph discussing alignment
with Russia, Hungary, Poland,
Brazil, India.
Analyze that shared DNA not just
as like an emotion right, but as
a conscious political choice,
the commitment to national
sovereignty and traditionalism.
Yes, and contrast that directly
with the perceived liberal
internationalism of the EU and
NATO.
You use that great phrase, an
arranged marriage.
Frame the normie stance as a
positive political defense of
the nation state that gives it
equal analytical weight and
complexity.
And we should probably get
specific about democracy too,
how the normie view of, say, one
man, one vote, one time clashes
directly with the activist focus
on equity and protecting the
vulnerable.
Absolutely show why the former
is seen by that group is a
necessary defense against what
they perceive as globalist or
activist overreach.
It gives that side the
intellectual justification that
might feel a bit underdeveloped
currently.
OK, that makes the three faces
feel much more balanced in terms
of analytical depth.
It really captures that
paralysis you talk about.
Precisely, it shows why the
conflict is so intractable.
Good.
OK, Third Point.
This one's about maybe deepening
the originality, drawing a
stronger theoretical line.
You suggest linking the critique
of modern Vanguard more
explicitly to the academic
concept of Palin Genesis, that
idea of radical cultural
rebirth.
Yeah, I think this could be a
really powerful conceptual
bridge right now.
The analysis of the vanguard
being disposable, exploiting the
vulnerable, the useful Kleenex
idea.
It draws on critiques of Marxist
revolutionary cycles, you know,
Lenin, Tom Wolfe, cultural
purges, which is all valid and
important.
But it feels maybe a little
disconnected from the core
argument about the meaning of
fascism itself.
Exactly.
It's a strong critique, but how
does it tie back directly to the
semantic confusion around
fascism?
We need to connect the activist
drive for like ideological
purity and a racing culture back
to the revolutionary core of
historical fascism.
And palangenesis is the
theoretical tool for that.
It's essentially about
revolutionary cleansing, right?
This mythic promise of washing
away the corrupt old order,
whether through racial purity or
in other cases, cultural purity,
to birth a completely new,
strong national body, that
utopian totalizing impulse was
central to historical fascism.
OK, so the suggestion is use
palangenesis as a lens to
structure the discussion of
revolutionary ambition not just
in historical fascism but also
in the malice influenced
activist model you describe.
Yes, by doing that you can frame
the activists Dr. erasing
tradition and smashing culture
to make way for a new world,
that Maoist lineage as a kind of
contemporary, maybe inverted
manifestation of that same
palangenic myth.
It's still a revolutionary push
for total non negotiable
cultural unity, just aimed
perhaps at a different enemy or
ideal, but it shows a deeper
shared ideological structure
between the seemingly opposed
radical forces.
That really does add a layer of
originality.
It gives the reader a more
sophisticated tool for
understanding these movements.
So a concrete example might be
linking the activist desire to
be the caretakers, guardians of
the vulnerable, back to that
utopian nature of palangenesis.
Exactly.
Show how both historical fascist
movements and certain modern
revolutionary forces imagine
themselves as the sole righteous
arbiters of the new body politic
that needs to be born from the
ashes of the old.
It reframes the activist
behavior not just as, say,
hypocritical, but as embodying a
form of utopian cleansing
radicalism that shares
structural echoes with the very
thing they claim to fight.
That's a much deeper connection.
Very insightful.
OK, final point then.
This one is more about flow and
impact, specifically around that
powerful skateboard metaphor in
the conclusion, right?
It describes how symbols get
emptied and repurposed.
It's a great image, but maybe it
could be set up earlier,
foreshadowed somehow so it lands
with even more force.
I agree The essay uses several
really strong metaphors already.
The firmware updates, ghosts
versus threats, the NIMBY
paradox, they all work well.
But the skateboard as the sort
of final summing up image for
weaponized semantic drift.
It's visually striking,
definitely, but it feels like it
comes out in nowhere right at
the end.
Yeah, the reader is sort of
bracing for a summary of the
crisis, and instead this vivid
but new visual metaphor appears
in the last moments.
The impact feels maybe slightly
abrupt because we haven't been
primed to think about familiar
objects being weaponized in
quite that way until the final
paragraph.
That's the slight weakness.
So the suggestion is simply to
weave that theme symbol,
repurposing weaponization into
the introduction.
Somehow set a more dynamic
visual tone for the whole piece
right from the start.
Introduce the idea of
weaponization earlier.
Strategically smart for the
flow.
So maybe in those opening
paragraphs talking about
semantic drift, you could slip
of the sentence that anticipates
the end.
Something like the word hasn't
just drifted, it's been
repurposed, like a familiar tool
of youth culture suddenly turned
into a blunt force weapon.
Something along those lines.
Oh, that works perfectly.
It plants the seed.
It makes the final image feel
earned, like the culmination of
that theme.
And then we just need to make
sure that final statement about
the skateboard being swung at
the skull of America itself
lands clearly as the climax of
the whole emotional and semantic
conflict you've described
throughout, not just a sudden
closing thought.
Got it.
OK.
So let's just quickly recap
those 4 core suggestions for the
listener.
First, integrate corporatism
much earlier and more
dynamically for that historical
and economic rigor.
Second, balance the analysis by
fleshing out the positive
political program of the normie
perspective.
Sovereignty tradition, right?
Third, use palingenesis to
connect the critique of the
modern vanguard more deeply back
to the historical analysis of
fascism.
Yes, and 4th foreshadow or plant
that powerful skateboard
metaphor earlier to maximize its
concluding impact.
Exactly.
And look, the piece is already
very compelling.
It's tackling something
incredibly important for right
now, implementing these steps,
especially getting that economic
definition integrated and
balancing the weight of the
three faces.
We'll just ensure that central
argument about semantic
confusion is really anchored in
rigorous analysis, historically
and politically.
It'll give it the maximum
robustness and impact it
absolutely deserves.
We really believe in pushing
ourselves to get better.
We hope these suggestions are
helpful and we'd invite you to
implement them.
And feel free to submit the
revised material for the. 3
conflicting Definitions of
fascism OK, so here's the deal.
We're diving into why America
seems to have totally lost the
plot on what fascism or anti
fascism even means.
And you know, the source
material argues this huge
semantic split, it's actually
tearing the nation apart.
First, let's talk about the
original academic idea.
It really centers on
corporatism.
Think of society as one giant
body, a corpus, right?
So private businesses and
property, yeah, they exist, but
they're completely stripped of
autonomy.
They have to serve the goals of
the authoritarian state.
It was originally seen as this
kind of third way, you know,
something between chaotic
capitalism and revolutionary
communism.
Second, you've got this
fundamental split in how we
understand it today.
Older Americans often view
fascism pretty narrowly,
basically Hitler and the Nazis
from World War 2.
So for them anti fascism, that's
America itself, the victory in
45.
But younger activists define
fascism much more broadly,
seeing things like borders,
nationalism, Christianity, even
tradition as part of a fascist
system.
Their anti fascism it's often
more about dismantling those
kinds of hierarchies, finally
ignoring that original meaning.
Corporatism is why the words
kind of failing us now.
When fascism gets boiled down to
just racism and camps or
stretched so wide it means
anything traditional, it loses
its power as a useful political
category.
It just becomes this vague moral
insult.
You know, like bad vibes.
Authoritarianism.
This massive language gap means
both sides think they're the
anti fascists but they can't
even recognize each other's
definitions.
Swapping precise political
history for fuzzy cultural
insults.
Well, it's creating a vocabulary
crisis that just shuts down
conversation.